te souviens-tu du jour où tu as rejoint
ton père sur le tournage de la bible
à rome
[Applaudissements]
oui je fais mon image de euh de mon père
était il était le personnage de noé et
il conduisait les animaux dans l'arche
et tous les  les animaux le suivaient
et c'était la première image que j'avais de
mon père en train de travailler et
ça avait l'air tellement amusant que j'ai
décidé que je voulais faire ce que mon père
faisait et j'ai découvert plus tard que cela signifiait
un réalisateur quel est le jean de ton père
houston le trésor du film préféré du grand maestro
de la sierra madre la raison en
est que mon grand-père walter houston
était sur la photo et ils ont tous deux remporté des
oscars pour la photo et c'est l'un
des meilleurs films d'aventure euh que j'ai
jamais vu tu te bats toujours  comme ton
père l'a fait contre la colorisation du
faucon maltais
oui nous avons gagné un procès ici en france
pour la colorisation de la jungle d'asphalte
et euh l'affaire s'est très bien déroulée et nous
et tout allait bien seulement j'ai reçu une
lettre l'autre d  ay de ted turner
disant qu'il va faire appel et euh
il va encore le porter devant le tribunal donc
j'espère pouvoir m'en sortir sans
perdre ma chemise euh quelle est la meilleure
[musique]
pas les temps sur les plateaux de tournage euh
ou  avec des gens glamour mais les
moments de silence en regardant l'océan au
mexique en
jouant au backgammon en
buvant du whisky et en
étant juste amis quel est le dernier
conseil que ton père a bien donné
en ce qui concerne le film il euh il a
dit choisis une histoire que tu admires
quelque chose qui  vous aimez et traduisez
cela fidèlement à l'écran et
diffusez-le correctement si vous pouvez faire ces deux
choses
vous êtes probablement sur la bonne voie pour réussir
votre père a donné l'opportunité
à votre sœur angelica votre frère
tony et à vous danny de travailler sur  ses
films quel est le patrimoine le plus précieux
qu'il vous a donné eh bien c'est une opportunité de
travailler
qui est l'une des choses les plus précieuses
que l'on puisse donner à un individu
et pour moi en particulier il m'a donné un
scénario fantastique  le scénario de
mr north as-tu d'autres projets pour que
ta belle soeur angelica retravaille
avec toi
euh
pas de projet précis car je crois
que
c'est l'histoire qui doit nous réunir
pas notre envie de travailler ensemble euh donc
il y a quelques choses  dans le futur avec
lequel je pourrais la voir
s'impliquer mais ce doit être à cause de l'
histoire pas à cause de notre désir quelle est
votre
relation avec votre
beau-frère jack nicholson
eh bien jack est euh est euh la plus sorte
de lubrique  euh
il a la plus merveilleuse
expression sale sur son visage qui me fait
tellement rire que vous ne pouvez pas imaginer et
c'est toujours un moment très agréable d'
être avec lui et
euh et il a un sens de l'humour qui est
euh qui est très sale  que j'aime beaucoup
comment pourriez-vous me convaincre de voir mr
north votre film
euh ça va vous faire du bien
euh
vous avez
votre routine quotidienne qui est très
réaliste dans votre vie j'en suis sûr et
vous pouvez vivre un moment de magie
et  été  tertain et quitter le cinéma
avec un sourire sur votre visage pouvez-vous
expliquer comment votre père avant
qu'il ne soit sur le point de mourir
vous a donné l'information qu'il
allait être remplacé par le grand robert
mitchum oui il m'a appelé quand j'étais à newport
rhode island  et il a dit que danny est-ce que
ça va si j'envoie le scénario à robert
mitchum juste au cas où
euh
et ma réponse était bien sûr si cela
vous fait vous sentir mieux c'est la bonne chose à
faire
finalement il n'a pas pu être dans le
jeu le personnage  et mitchum a pris le relais
mitchum était prêt nous avons passé une excellente journée de
tournage et à la fin de la journée nous avons
rendu visite à mon père à l'hôpital et
mitchum a dit john et je suis vraiment désolé je
n'ai jamais pensé que je devrais te remplacer
dans quoi que ce soit et mon  la réponse du père
était
ne vous inquiétez pas bob c'est l'un des plus gros
canular que j'ai jamais fait
et il nous a vraiment trompé en ayant
robert mitchum pouvez-vous nous donner quelques
réflexions
sur la façon dont
vous avez travaillé avec les grands noms comme
robert mitchum
et la grande diva loren b  occar
oui robert mitchum est
vraiment un homme et
et le matin je dirais
bob um comment vas-tu aujourd'hui et il
dirait pire
et je pense mon dieu mais pourquoi chaque matin
quand je te vois tu dis que tu es pire il
dit  eh bien une fois j'étais en irlande et
j'ai demandé à un de mes bons amis comment il allait
et il a dit qu'il allait bien la prochaine chose que j'ai
su qu'il est tombé mort à mes pieds donc à partir de
maintenant je dis que je suis pire c'est d'accord avec
toi
et euh lauren bacall est quelqu'un qui
quand elle entre sur le plateau, la première chose que
vous voyez est son bras et sa main tendus
et vous attrapez sa main vous la
conduisez sur le plateau et tout le monde
sait qu'elle est là c'est une diva c'est un
star
est mr north
votre premier film
ou est-ce le dernier film de votre père
eh bien c'est euh je pense que c'est à la fois euh
c'est euh mes
débuts au cinéma et c'est mon entrée dans
l'industrie cinématographique et c'est le
dernier effort de mon père dans l'industrie cinématographique alors euh
vraiment, il nous unit de cette façon
spécifiquement
vous bleu